hi I'm Brianna from free cocaine today
we're going to be talking about git and
github how you use them when you use
them and some of the differences between
the two to start off let's talk about
git git is a version control software
which means while you're coding you can
save each little time you make a change
so if you make a mistake you want to
undo something or you just want to look
back and see how it was before you can
do that with git git is also open source
you can find get to download on at git
SCM comm they also have great resources
for documentation now let's talk about
github you've probably been on github
before for some free code camp things
noticed it there you probably even have
an account github is a collaboration
website that interacts with git and
works with it on the projects that you
work on in your version control it's
hard to tell where the line is between
what's git and what's github that's okay
you don't have to know what you need to
remember is you'll use github to
interact with git they'll use it to
collaborate with your peers on projects
using version control